But I parked your curiosity for languages on a big you know
when I think of the university in one thousand nine hundred eighty three I started studying out of mystic studies I
attended courses in morphology syntax
and I found out that most of the linguistic phenomena couldn't be explained by you know by the normal you know
methodology which we follow in Arabic studies usually the tradition of extent this.
In fact in the future after I got my B.A. and I had to stick at.
There were if you're looking invest in one thousand and eighty seven. I attended master program in referee.
Is the study of ancient inscriptions in general. Whether it's in size and rock or metal or on wood.
There are many surfaces and we can talk about many surfaces were inscriptions written and in fact this is study.
I mean studying it bigger.
If you institute of archaeology and anthropology pave my way to understand more about the prehistory I mean I mean the.
History of Arabic and of fact. In general and also gives me the opportunity discover more about.
Because history of pins and I before Islam goes through the inscriptions we discover usually.
Facts related to religious the.
Religious beliefs and Abia as well as historical facts that are not listed in the Arabic sources
or in the Arabic tradition.
What I mean that studying Arabic and out of a culture
and general would not yield to you know to useful conclusions without studying the ancient languages in general.
I mean every students who attend.
I mean who would like to study Arabic and maybe a culture should start you know maybe from the tenth century B.C.
To have a wide understanding and understanding about the baby and peninsula and its history its religions
and languages.
If you started studying that was it you study was it like for you to first of all at one of us in fact my group in fact
and nineteen thousand nine hundred eighty seven were the second group who attended which attended the bigger of the at
the Institute of archaeology and anthropology and we are now more than thirty professors spread over Jordan and.
Worldwide.
And this gives us of course an impulse to work to work on further to discover our cultural heritage I mean our
linguistic and cultural heritage in general. In fact. I'm OK I'm at the animal conversing Now when I started before.
But my stay in Germany in fact I invested my stay in Germany to go. In this study and.
I tried my best to through you know.
Through German language discover more and more about the culture and the cultural history to live on live on time and.
Also the Horn of Africa. And I'm also interested in that relationship between the Horn of Africa.
In addition to historical spectrum. Covered by my study either through a period in Germany.
And German period you discovered or you discover probably before
but what I like what your German period which you describe is how you somehow through language learning the German
language discovered more and more of the German soldiers Germany tortured you of course I mean OK the.
I mean learning German was great importance for me it's the way forward to understand.
Literature in written German in general and as you know German
or any language it is a kind of a key it's a key to the culture itself.
Not only to literature but also to the people I mean if you understand that I know if you can deal with the language.
It means that you can discover the culture as well. You know.
And German is of course a living language it's language it's been spoken by lots of people in Germany.
You know you went to studying languages that are. Yes in fact. Well yes.
If you if you know the system of a certain language then it will be easy for you to learn other languages.
I mean I don't I talk now about you know grammar. I'm not talking about the script.
You know
and yes I had the background how to deal with languages in German that was for me that's why it was for me easy to
learn German and also to deal with it and to write a lot of articles and publications in German.
But when you say once you know how can you have easy access to the keys of languages and of inscriptions.
But having those keys.
You're generation is one of the first maybe that you really mean if I say generation I mean the generation Jordan.
I mean but I mean Europeans. Look at about this under two hundred years ago since two hundred.
I mean we are not the first in this field. You know studying ancient culture and I mean I've been in live and.
I mean the European Union in this regard.
Well of course and also they contributed inscriptions my generation which started abroad.
The same with the same experience the same information. They gained. I mean the Europeans has again before.
And of course I mean I mean on a daily. I mean there are you know. Inscriptions.
Are discovered you know constantly and some of them are still undecided for it.
But what we have of course I mean inscriptions and languages that we understand and we can deal with the ethics and.
Conclude from the text either on the linguistic cultural or any other level.
But I can imagine that such a beautiful thing that you discover through inscriptions through understanding languages
that you're discovering for cultures the former. Yes in fact inscriptions are a repository of history.
Of course if you decipher.
I mean if you discover an inscription it means that you can understand a lot about the environment
or the locality where the inscription is found in certain cases you can date the site
and archaeological site through the inscription.
I mean not only pottery but also other inscription and material can help us in dating archaeological sites
and we have now I mean if you get if you if the inscription is dated for example then.
Now you have fixed date of a certain site but sometimes your graph.
I mean the way you write inscriptions also gives you indications about you know gives you up a little bit someone
formation about they think about dating the site but not. Not an exact details. Yeah I mean.
Also I mean if you discover an inscription which is a new and you are the first one who understand understand it
and then you convey to the humanity and new experience in new information that.
In my opinion of great importance to understand the human creativity and the and when you discover such a right
when you decipher such an inscription
and you know what does that do for it opens your window to it to do to a culture that was once here.
You know of course I mean you understand. As soon as you discover and decipher inscription and understand it.
Of course it opens a window to a lot of historical facts and. Cultural historical facts. About the region.
It is this covered and when you say that you are generation is one of the first from Jordan yes.
Yes Again what we're doing research on these interruptions and.
What does that mean that you are the first from this region to do that. What a sense of well. In fact.
It means a lot means that we have no generation from you know from Jordan I mean from the area from the region in
general which can deal with its cultural heritage and understand it and the standard.
You know and the same historical and do graphical context. You know if I talk about.
OK I mean Europeans contributed in the fighting the inscriptions they contributed in
and they were standing the inscriptions
but sometimes some of them of course some of them a lack of the cultural background.
You know I mean I have to say that frankly I mean some of them they like to the cultural background therefore I mean
there and there is. Sending of the entire story is a little bit vague. You know but of course I mean now.
In fact we are not working alone here we are working. Also with our European colleagues in Europe.
Mainly in Europe and the United States and other countries.
And we exchange of opinions about certain issues in this regard
and after that we reach a conclusion in which you bring in some extra Yes layer because very importantly because you
are from from from the same region.
Yes but I don't I have to say that my European colleagues also help in different and different perspectives.
I mean we conduct joint surveys we conduct also joint studies together.
And I think it's important not sort of from the center of a perspective but also from the cultural perspective.
Because it's important to get in contact with our European colleagues and I mean not only Europeans
but outside Jordan I mean our colleagues from outside Jordan to have exchanges which means that we can do more for
cultural and that is standing as well. If it where you say that your.
As you were born here your race you are part of this culture and you are one of the first. Working.
If you don't understand.
That makes you can imagine it's that's a very special role you have very important probably very special.
Yes I can't I personally can't evaluate myself and whether I am that I have a special role or not it's the academic.
Again they're called to decide this you know I mean I'm not the one who decides that because I can't do is you shed
light all the time. That people here. Before you know much about you know just again this is true and this is true in.
I mean some generations. I mean. What I want to say that.
To be broad broad minded and accept the opening of others is of a Great is a crucial to understand and to exchange.
Exchange ideas and also to reach reliable conclusions. I think that who was who would like to study this.
Culture in general should have a broad knowledge about a lot of things you know not only history not only languages
but also ancient history and also more than. Modern history and ancient cultures and modern culture.
I mean they are not separated you cannot separate them because I mean.
Who lived in this area for a long time I think I mean they exist there existed after that I mean what I'm talking about
is the change of political entities in but the people are the same the people are the same and they also.
You know continue to live in this in this area in this region and I think we have to take into consideration.
I mean a lot of perspectives to towards studying a certain topic on certain subjects in our cultural history. It is.
I mean I mean studying the past is connected with that with our living our living had it it. We cannot separate them.
But the fact that you shed light on times that that before people wouldn't know much about because it was not you know
what where why why is that why is it that you are one of the first to do just that I have some colleagues who are older
than me and did that. Of course but.
I think it's important to have a generation who you know interested in its cultural heritage and cultural history
and you what I want to say is you by by being one of the first Jordanian professor now
but the one of the scientists researching investigating inscriptions and languages
and shedding light all the time that somehow is not known about water. Why is it that times.
What makes it that those times were not to see him or not accepted or not embraced by before.
Yes because you know I mean if I think that I've been I mean as an example for example that TRUTH ABOUT THAT I CAN they
were concerned with the bins and its history.
They didn't get in fact the axes to enchant sources because at that time they couldn't they hadn't the instruments.
That you know give them the axis for example to ancient South Arabia. Not that I've been to. Or.
I mean we are talking about two hundred years all discipline. I mean not not that of that ancient let all. Yeah.
And we can expect that such a big source is not covered mean they're covered maybe two hundred years before Islam for
example but they don't go deeper into history because the composer
and the authors didn't have access to such to such an approach because source. So that's why it's important to.
They're going to consideration of the archaeological sources because sources as well as. Maybe oral history as well.
It's also important in oral history it's important to understand ancient cultures because the same people are still
living in the same people who you know established ancient cultures I mean their descendants are still still very you
know
and that's why I feel it's important to study in a holistic approach where we can take into consideration because African
sources the archaeology and also to living heritage but
when you say like the like before the ancient cultures were not really part of the storytelling of their rhetoric
history. It's That's now changing and I suspect because you bring them the stories of those days.
Yes this is now we have. New Window to ancient history of the arrogant Peninsula.
This is a new
and this new window was not possible to open without studying you know finding inscriptions of this happening the
ancient ancient Arabian and semantic inscriptions in general
and what does this this window because I suppose much of the students you get they are taught in a way that they don't
understand our styles before you know how did you. How do they. That area that era when they come in your your faculty.
Yeah that's a good question.
In fact the students who come to our faculty they have their own you know ideas about at Abia
or about the symmetry cultures in general.
But when they get to the plea involved in this field they start they start changing their their understanding
and also their methodology towards the studying. The cultural history of the semantic world.
But what is their view when they call me.
Well how do you how do they see that when they don't have to it's not it's a kind of economic times
and in fact most of our students who are coming to in fact. They are selected you know because they know I mean.
They know in prayer. What are they going to do you know.
And then because they have a little bit you know a little knowledge about this
and about the cultural history of Arabia and this in the quad in general. But at the institute.
We train them and we conduct surveys so that they understand what we are doing in a better way.
But what is the because I suppose the view that they have nor are the people from Jordan and from the Arabian.
What how do they see in general the times before.
Well in fact of flourishing they had a flourishing civilization and Arabian for Islam and word ignorance period.
I think it's not the right word to use in this context because you know ignorance it means that the people who were
living there were ignorant and. They were not in contact with civilization is certain about this is in fact.
A little bit you know it's I mean the idea should be defined a little bit in fact Arabia witnessed flourishing culture.
I mean economy.
Historically and culturally in general
and it's our role now to present this culture which is which was hidden in the inscriptions that you're all. Present.
I mean to present to present the contents of this ancient heritage to be absorbed by the young generation because it's
part of their identity. It's part of their history and I think it's our role now to.
To make them aware that Arabia is not you know I mean I mean maybe generally yet in terms of religious of religious
perspective but from the civilized perspective I think specially the south and parts
and the central parts of great importance and significance for to understand. I mean the OK and what's not.
I think the sources.
Give us a new glimpse I mean the ancient source is there in an instant inscriptions that give us a new glimpses on the
hidden history and the hidden. Culture of Arabia before Islam. And this is you know now evident I mean.
Even through research and through archaeological surveys and through also started studies published. You know.
I mean I mean we have thousands of publications in this regard.
But most of them in fact are written in foreign languages that's why they are not accessible by the people
and it's I want to roll now to I mean not to translate.
This huge literature but also to present to present the cultural history of every viewer in Arabic.
This is I think this is important. So that people can have access to the source.
And when you have you studied several languages you let You can lay connections.
So you create worlds that had been here now before I was not understood by people I mean you mean there's clearly both
if you're sick you're you're putting a light on times that that for most people was not known yet.
So people understand now that for example you better. This is the culture of what it stands for.
Yes of course about I have to say that I'm not the first one of the. No of course I know but you know understanding.
I mean if you talk about big or a few
or the ancient languages yes of course as I said in the beginning there are in fact.
The key to cultures and Betty and inscriptions are written in about the end language in about the end script
and if you decide for the script then you understand the language and you understand after that the contents of.
Over certain inscription and from this inscription you can extract and grow conclusions regarding. Religious history.
Regarding commercial issues regarding. Social relations among people at that time.
I mean through this knowledge and you can nurtured the.
You know the history of this region of course it is it's do you see that also that there are connections between the
pre-reading worlds
and Arab world that somehow I mean like do you see connections that before had not been seen between the previous let
me grow old you know because of course yes yes of course because people you know continue to exist in every view
and of course the. Good with them you know and traditions that continued until nowadays. Do you have examples of that.
Well let's say something some ancient South
and maybe in inscriptions from Yemen from Grant from presenteeism And in fact we rely on human idea.
It's to understand ancient inscriptions. Because some words that the king. Not in ancient South Arabian inscriptions.
They are still used in Yemen. You know I mean. And this is this is a fact you know. And also some rituals that existed.
I mean that we know from the inscriptions still exist and existing until nowadays you know in human.
And which means that this culture continued to exists a part of political change is a part of economics changes
but people have preserved the skill shot and edited. And continue to transmit it.
It's a gamble bureau or certain other. Oh it's something different. It's something the surface.
One and something different. I mean the coming burial inscriptions. OK it's from. But OK I mean.
This is an evidence about the resurrection. And the people in Arabia used to bury their camels with them.
So that they can rest. OK. Where this obsession for languages and inscriptions started.
Well in fact this passion started after my being in fact doing my be a study in Jordan at Yarmouk universities
and see I'm looking versity I tried my best to understand the culture in a more deep and with a more depth
but I didn't find my you know. I didn't find this in doing might be a start. Is as you know.
Because we were studying Arabic
and stick in general in the traditional way studying the languages in a sing I mean not in the UK.
Way but in synchronic way.
Well I started looking for programs that you know that could help me in decipher the ancient history of Arabic in
general and the ancient history of Arabian culture and that was after nineteen eighty seven
when I attended a master program at the Institute of archaeology and anthropology.
Where I started and I finished my degree of theme.
And my master's thesis was concerned with the relationship with the relationship between big and you're going to tick.
Are you going to think is one of the Bronze Age Late Bronze Age languages that existed on the Mediterranean Sea and.
I tried to find the lexical affinities between we call them some scholars call the classical Arabic or.
Standard and of a lot of different terminology. I mean here the Arabic of course and the pretty Islamic and A.B.
and Poetry.
And I found out that there are a lot of aspects that you know constitute the kind of Sickle similarity between you
going to take and and I back. And yes because this could be of course explain because both languages.
They have the same mother language which we call it.
It's a hypothetical language we call it brought a semantic and this looks talk could be you know from this.
From this genetic relationship. But it could be.
Also I mean this relationship could be also through historical historical factors when I mean by. Migrations by.
You know historical contacts commercial contacts etc But I mean that we have a lot of historical models to explain this
similarity. But in general I mean most of the languages in live and the Levant and Arabia.
And also in misery theme in there are interconnected
and we call them Sister languages because they come from the same from the same origin or origin.
We call it similar proto symmetry and I wanted to record what is your fashion nation your photos of languages.
Yes because I found in general I found the languages.
I mean studying the language to provide us with them the right instruments to decipher cultures.
For example I did forty five years ancient If you pick all if you pick language because my professor
and Bellina Professor Reiner folk too as I mean you said you know and professor in this field.
And I did with him five years studying you know engine if you if you pick
and why because I wanted to understand the relationship between Arabia and the Horn of Africa.
I mean you know studying the language you know would explain a lot of historical facts and.
Circle phenomena in terms of relationship between Arabia and the Horn of Africa is an example
and as I said to you because I was interested in exploring the history of Arabic language and the Arabic culture
and Dylan in general. Where did it.
Even before your studies where did this fascination for languages and for for for just read
but it really just was in fact in general I was interested in languages.
Even during my childhood
and that's why I was interested in English from the beginning although I was studying Arabic and.
Because I found I found out that studying certain language would open and pave the way for.
For me to get information about certain. About certain aspects of our cultural history.
I mean from the beginning I was interested in languages but I can see how this. How this world at the beginning.
I mean. You know. But when you were really young. I mean when you were ten or eleven What how did how did it.
How did it show. What. What was a fascination. First a nation and languages. I can't remember.
I mean I can't make it since this is
and this regard your book did you want to discover the world to understand the world with did you just want to be usual
Veron or. I don't know I can say that you know we had no internet at that time T.V.
Also was not accessible at that time because I am.
I was born in a village where electricity didn't exist at that time one thousand eight hundred two.
And you know we had and that was the. Window to the world you know.
And of course I hear a lot of languages and the radio. I mean. I found out later that this is German.
This is French you know and that I couldn't you know differentiate between German French or Dutch or Swedish
or Russian but you know this. I mean when I started to hear.
I mean there were voices only voices you know for me and
but there are certain points where the pronoun pronunciation is different from. Different different.
I mean different from each other.
And maybe this is one of the one of the reasons why I was interested I mean I mean I was interested in languages
because how did you listen and you were like.
Suppose in the living room where how did you know that you could find different languages. You know I can't.
It wasn't in the living room of course I mean I don't understand your question how do you know it's a radio you know
you you go you you hear those language you how did you do that where you just scrolling through the channels for us
and scrolling through just channels and trying to even even within the out of it was fair. You know and I tried to.
You know we have many Derrick's here and I don't and it was for me at the beginning difficult to understand.
For example of the moral conduct and this is one.
This is one example of why I have the right instruments to study languages because it's also there could be considered
as languages because sometimes they have different morphology and different syntax and this made me also.
Yes Dick to the person who's studying languages in fact I can't.
If I factor is why I was interested in languages from the beginning.
I don't know I have no president since this is about this.
You are from of you're from a family that it's also a scientific interest or. Yes In fact in my family.
In fact they were interested. I mean my father is a businessman and.
My family in general used to and money through business and it was my uncle in fact my elder uncle who supported me
and.
You know opened my academic world because he is considered one of the first to graduate from the Jordan University.
And you fact he supported my career in my studies
and also opened my eyes towards you know towards the world because he got in contact with the people in our man
and the capital city and also worldwide. That's why he wanted me to.
You know to deviate from the carrier of my family you know and it did it. And when you described your. Well.
What sparked your curiosity. Well. Regarding languages.
Well in fact I am a patient guy and I have to say I am very very patient in even from a child.
I used to help my father in his store and in his business since I was seven years old. In fact I have to. That.
And this caused you know this part of my life shaped my life and. To be a serious person.
And because I didn't in fact I didn't enjoy most of the children my age enjoyed before you know and.
My father wanted me to be OK. The biz the monk the.
And the village and he sent me first to Roman Catholic school that wasn't one nine hundred seventy
and the story of my get them applying for my. Is and my you know my school life started them.
But it due to the problems that occurred in in Jordan at that time.
My father preferred that I come back to the village and study them.
And continue the studying They're doing my preparatory my elementary preparatory
and secondary schooling I did it in the village in fact even in a village in nearby.
And they used to walk from my house to their village for three kilometers sometimes. And maybe this. Any This walk.
You know stimulated me to think about the world
and about sometimes the creation about lot of things you know usually I mean usually.
School boys think sometimes some of them they don't think I think about it because they have other interests. And.
In fact even even this influenced my life in my future life in the university even in Germany and also later I can see.
I can see. During the element preparatory and elementary. Period pieces.
I used to study Arabic poetry ancient Arabic poetry. And I was fascinated in fact.
With the contents of the Arabic poetry and how they can be recited and ethnic mix time.
And but I was interested also to understand the words integrate and used in this.
Such passages political passages
and I can assure you of that later I found out that our teacher sometimes they explained in a traditional ways
explained some words in a traditional way.
But I was not convinced you know I was not convinced mostly in their explanations
and I kept this until I went to the university in one thousand eight hundred three where I attended the Arabic program.
University and we went in fact with assistance of professors of Arabic studies we went in depth to study
and studying the ancient poetry but I mean. The problem. I didn't find a solution for my problem.
I mean how to understand.
The Arabic poetry in a proper way and how what are the origins of some certain words and this.
And this Arabic poetry and also I mean to explain how linguistic phenomena.
Could be you know how could we explain linguistic phenomena and in Arabic and particularly in within this wide context.
I mean within this wide Arab country Arabic context were Arabic is used.
You know as you know Arabic is use in different parts of the world. In fact that was not enough for me because I.
You know I started to excavate and to dig for the origins of Arabic and I found my I found some of the answer.
During my studies. My misters where we exposed to.
In fact I have so European experience I was taught by different European professors
and American professors at the Institute of archaeology and anthropology at that time we were exposed to.
And also I mean we attended courses to study for example can I to ancient South Arabian if you pick.
Certain And there are all of those language of these languages are sister languages
and to go back to one to one source or to one origin which we called proto Semitic now. Well.
Well this in fact open paved the way for my future research and since then I was interested in studying get more
and more more languages to understand and its context in a proper way but what makes that. Now you unique in the world.
It makes you know why I'm afraid of this world unique.
Yeah well I'm trying to connect and to find the relationship between Arabic and its cultural and linguistic. Context.
This is this is what I'm trying to show to. My not only to my colleagues or to my.
Students and also to make it known abroad this. I mean this methodology was was not known in fact in the Arab world.
I mean how to connect on a big with its surrounding languages through ages and also the culture where Arabic managed.
Yeah. Well this influence of course my future studies and future research I did my I did my M.
A thesis on the relationship between Arabic and you've got to take it because because an important source.
Because it's a language with existed and continue it exists and the Levant also and of course and North Africa.
Here we hear and then you know.
And then alas I mean as you know and we have like prayers five prayers this is the we call it
and then I'll ask that which comes after afternoon. You said a certain moment in your when you were young.
Listen listen to this Arabic poetry. And.
Read sort of short In fact it was included in the curriculum the school year
and also I hear that you know some people improvise that you know and I was interested in understanding the meaning.
Of this point three in a proper way but you know huge We usually people resigned this poetry
but they sometimes don't understand because her background of this point three
and I was interested in the cultural background not only on the high.
To be recited it's beautiful
but I want to understand interested in understand the standing the cultural dimensions of this poetry
and its language to you Mr in the. Sight of you know this is this is what I missed in fact during my school period.
Also I can see even during my me a period
and at the university because they used to teach us in a traditional way you know trying to explain it couldn't you
know you know explain the cultural background of this poetry and not only the cultural backgrounds but also.
The contained items that were for me very difficult to understand as as anger.
You know because maybe in poetry represents the Arabic where to represents a very old stage of the Arabic literature
and and it was I don't I can't I can't say that it was disconnected from the people
but it was represented a certain cultural phase and Arabian Peninsula
and I was you know in future stages of my life I was interested in to understand the cultural background
and the cultural context of this poetry
and also the beginning slam I mean the language of Koran was also for me a very difficult language to understand I
think and I think we can should some light on the core
and acting from different languages that existed in Arabia before Islam because some words they continued to be used.
Continue to be.
At the time and also they were part of the quote an activist and I was interested in and understanding such words
and and I have some research on this regard. They have. I started the project on this regard.
Can you do you remember the poem the first poem that makes you. Well then in fact.
I'm interested in the breeze let me get a B. and Put it three which goes back to the so-called J.
Three or the generally age or the ignorance period for example
and I had been any other well known I know I mean I mean well and also I wouldn't want to
and other people other people
but you know I was not I wasn't prepared to do this you know because if you're not then I'd like to go back to the last
thing which you said about a critic could I make.
Yeah
but what if you feel what to what are you doing with your say your use you see you see that also not as disconnected
from the people but it's somehow it's a language form that it's not.
I mean I mean I mean the poetry was OK It was not definitely not connected it was it you know
and a cultural context of course because this boy three describes of it people describes their relationship with their
environment.
Describes also their understanding of the world you know at that time I mean
when we go back to the court on what on if you were saying that you're now with what you're finding you were finding
you weren't also for the Koran. Or you find you. Not findings you know as well. No I mean. Well.
There are certain core and accords that could be interpreted in different ways you know I mean.
OK the Arab exhibits they contributed a lot to understanding
but in some cases we can do more for to understand this text through through the languages that existed in
and maybe at that time. Because it's they they are have all they're also their roots.
Yes of course I mean such words they have their own roots in their language about it before Islam
and yeah I mean we have for example some words that were you know they became Arabic you know although they are foreign
words foreign words but there they became Arabic and they became part of the Arabian linguistic culture
and you found in you found them. You know and different maybe and texts and also the period.
They are known some of them are known and the connected. Because they're not in fact.
They were they were foreign words but they were Arab eyes you know and they took the Arabic shape.
You know as you know as usual in interchange between languages. It's known you know.
You can you're discovering that now.
Well I'm trying to yeah you know to deal with certain words
and understanding to understand them in in a different context.
I mean to interpret them in the light of ancient semantic languages that existed in Arabia before Islam.
And how can you give examples. Yes there are some examples in.
For example the verse in National Park has been interpreted we opened your chests
and you know there are different interpretations
but we have to go back to for example to ancient South Arabian linguistic culture we find that the Shanahan means to
predict which means. In fact if we reinterpret.
It means that we I mean the god has protected Mohammed's brother Mohammed starts.
You know this is you know this helps us to understand the thinks in a better way
and it is in it's for the benefit of course and in fact you know it's there for the benefit of course I mean. To use.
I mean to use the languages and to shed light on through other language other Arabian languages. OK then we go back to.
When you were with your student you were with your students in the mountains.
You're looking at these storms in this norm of terrain with when you when you when you look for them for yourself
when you invision your your future your to dream of what they can do what you can do here in this area.
What what would you how do you envision that over ten fifteen years.
Well how do I envision my students or in the field and just sort of part of press room
when you look at your your your field of work with your students you walk into a bank research.
It's what you would you explain for what do you envision for the coming ten years.
What do you want them to find out that you yourself to find out. Well.
In fact I would like to continue in this field
and of course I hope that the can that my students can continue as well because this is a message that we have to hand
out to other future generations
and I hope that we can establish a kind of a school I mean a school academic school you know to understand that aims at
understanding.
Maybe in culture from and maybe in peninsula and also in their live
and that's what I am that there continue the same discipline and also the continue and also
and training of future generations and
when you look because you walk into limitations you said you were the first one that shed a light.
But much of the people you didn't see the light you know what do you think your students will.
What kind of Windows are able to open. Well I hope. You know.
I mean they can of course they CAN I don't know I mean it's of course their decision to follow my discipline or not.
But it's definitely the are going to contribute understanding. Culture and it's why the widest context.
I like them to I mean on the history of Arabic.
I mean I would advise them to work on the history of Arabic as a language and culture. And. For the future.
I think they're there because they are they have now a wide knowledge I mean a wide knowledge.
Modern Languages and also an ancient languages and they have also given ability they are capable to deal with.
With other cultures. I mean not only I mean another instance cultures also more than cultures in the world.
I think they have more opportunity than I have what they had before. And a lot of storms too.
Yes I mean I mean OK they have we have to continue I mean documenting the inscriptions spread spread all over the
Jordanian reign and I mean this needs. Many generations I mean. In the future to be prepared for this task you know.
It's not a task of one generation or two generations
and we have to train many generations so that they can continue documenting our cultural heritage.
Not only stones and inscriptions but also. You know archaeology and tangible heritage and intangible heritage.
You know I mean you can't divide culture you know into parts you know they are all are all interconnected you know a
lot of aspects that are interconnected and can you know by studying.
These aspects we can draw you know clear picture about about our culture. What are you doing now.
What was what is your. No different projects and research. And diverse in general.
While I'm now conducting a field work along. You know I mean. So field work which I'm going to continue.
For the next few years in the so called head of our region in the volcanic region we visited.
Because and I'm also trying to involve foreign institutions to. To work with me and in this field work.
I mean it is I mean we are trying to document as far as possible.
North Arabian inscriptions from north in Jordan and from from the so-called from the so-called northeast and bad.
It is has a lot of. I mean the surfaces of stones constitute an ideal canvas for writing inscriptions.
Those inscriptions I mean were written by people who you know who were in the area.
I mean maybe they had the big one collector but it is not definite.
And there is a countless number of inscriptions in this area
and they need to be documented for a future studies so that we understand more and more about the people
and the area and the history of the area around you hold you know this was a land of milk and.
You know I mean one big archeological black hole they were still have to discover.
Yes I mean I'm not the only person you know. In fact and my institute versity and the other Institute today.
You're have found out that we are trying to train.
Students
and to train new generation to take the burden you know to continue with this responsibility in studying their cultural
heritage.
Jordan
but it's so I want to say all these rocks have you have a story yourself you are one shot fired that found some of the
stories but I mean this is one big. Landscape of rocks want to get yes in fact this is this is true but.
This is this is I mean everywhere you find inscriptions everywhere you find.
Aspects of cultural heritage here in Jordan. And you as I said we need generations and generations.
That continue to document and study this cultural heritage.
It is evidence that this area contributed in the human history. It is an evidence.
What we see here is an evidence that this area this region contributed to the human creativity it's an evidence on cue
and human creativity and you know we are trying to. To widen the snail I mean to widen the spectrum of this knowledge.
Not only among the academics
but also among the local communities so that they can feel that they have you know they have all the history
and they are proud proud of the sort that they understand of all this really they're proud of it.
So yes this is our intention I mean not only studying the cultural heritage in academic way
but also to let people know to let the community know that they have been to story which contributed in the development
of humanity as part of the development of civilizations. It's quite a struggle. Yeah I mean.
I don't know but this is something. You know it is but this is evident you know I mean as you see you know. For you.
It's this is also. For the people. I mean for the people I don't think so.
I don't think that all people endured and it's evident for them that. That better off for example.
That it's contributed in the human development and human civil a civilization
and I mean my father for example he never visited Petra.
You know I mean he's from the local Jordanian community but he didn't visit the visit before you know.
Him and I'm speaking my myself you know. Why not.
Well you know he's you know he's seventy two years old he's a he has his own interests.
You know he's a businessman and he's not interested in.
This field but you know I well I promised him to take him to Petra and maybe in two years
and I'm trying to convince him you know but you know my concern is a difficult to convince him you are one hundred.
Yes I'm going to say this is this is the paradox is because I'm the one who should make him aware of our ancient.
Engine turreted but I'm now concerned. What you're saying is it's strange. Your father. Yes. You won't open the window.
Your father has to be convinced to join you looked through the window. Yes through my window.
Yes this is a kind of paradox you know I can't explain that bit
but he didn't get the right education to be aware of the importance of our cultural heritage
but we are trying this with a new generation now but when you look at this paradox because your father stands for.
Much more people. Stands for Jordan for the general opinion about it not the sort of general opinion.
You know I mean in his age. There are people who are interested in what interested in this heritage.
It's sometimes you feel alone it's sometimes difficult to know so much of those beautiful Eric era.
And those you see so many people are going to convince
or try to convince it's good it's also a lonely feeling that you have one of the few that stands.
Yes sometimes yes you know this is true. I feel myself myself sometimes.
Alone even among my colleagues you know and then there's the how come you know I mean I mean not in my faculty
but in general you know yeah but it was you know young generation now is interested in different things.
You know and I and Business Administration finance it's a thing I you know and. This field is not.
OK it's respected Jordan
but students mostly are interested are young generation is interested in majors through which they can add money.
You know. And I have to admit you know. Through archaeology and heritage.
This is sometimes difficult you know so that makes that makes you love it. Well yeah maybe.
Yes Yeah maybe but I have some colleagues here in Jordan with whom with whom I can communicate and exchange ideas
and I have also leagues from Europe and the states and the United States. And we exchange ideas and opinions.
But mostly we remain in the academic real you know that's that that's the problem and the challenge now how to.
Raise awareness about the importance.
I mean how to raise awareness among them community members about this important cultural heritage which should be
disseminated you know and get known to a wide range of people. This is a challenge.
I mean OK as an academic I do my part but there are other there are other parties that can work with us.
You know for example the media and media can reach everybody in his in his room
and I think we have to work on this now for the next stage. Yeah.
And the and then
when you do you start with the rest of your history of Georgia because it's also it has to be yet discovered
or as should be you know it had to be studied the schools covered explore. But I'm.
I'm just one person you know and that's why I said we have to build a generation to get involved in studying.
This culture. What is your.
What is your dream when you
when you think in ten fifteen years what what what what is it what's your ideal Jordan look like. Jordan.
You know your your and my field. If you your faith. Is I expect I hope and wish that we were going to.
Going to establish an academic school here in Jordan academic school not in terms of university
or in the way of thinking in this field and I think I am part of this generation now because I was trained in Jordan.
I mean for my be a and and I am very proud to get my first training in Jordan. And it was consolidated.
By my study in Germany and my in my academic stays in Europe and the in the United States
and I'm sure that we are going further
and tried with with them with the future generation of course to build this academic schools this. I mean academic.
School of thought and in the field of cultural heritage in general.
And when you look at the fields where you're researching where we were before you know.
It's like that's quite a lot of work also storms are all the stones already.
Not all of the stones
and we have seen yesterday we had to penetrate in the desert for forty four to forty kilometers to find a place to find
the site where we. Work before. And yes I mean there is a countless number of such inscriptions spread over the.
Stones of the desert right there in the north. I mean North Eastern bad.
And of course they need the expertise they need you know scholars they need more.
Trained students and also research institutions.
It was just a once a day that it was tablets you know a kind of research research center there you know
and the desert you know so that so that. Such inscriptions such such science can be easily accessible to us.
Yeah I mean this is one of my dreams you know the established research center out of them.
And where do they publish their findings.
Well usually we have either republished the findings in books published them
and journals in different languages German and.
Yeah I mean those languages are accessible for us and sometimes
and French because some colleagues some of my colleagues.
Graduated from France and England for example and there are some you know they prefer to write
and the languages they they master. And here in Jordan.
Yes of course we have in fact the economic situation and the level of education in Jordan is.
Good here and it has its has a high standard in comparison to other institutions. In the region but can you.
For example also stories that shed light on this era. Is it easy to to share it with the general public.
A lot then of course yes. Yeah this is yeah I mean we can share it with the public.
I mean we hold conferences about our new discoveries. I think it will we are planning for a workshop.
I think in two thousand and sixteen on this subject of a new discoveries
and Jordan new African discoveries in Jordan
and I mean there is no problem to share the information with the public because I mean sometimes we compose our
articles and research papers in Arabic and I mean Arabic is accessible for every for everybody in Jordan.
Nobody can imagine what I would also meaning is it is sometimes I suppose difficult.
To do when there you have a lot of people who think of the time before as ignorant time to.
To to to let them know look through this window you see you see. World. Yes.
Like what you're saying about about what you're doing with yeah yeah yeah you know better you know this through back
the best way is to do implement our to use the.
Modern media possibilities to make the people aware about what they are discovering.
And I'm trying my best now to convince my university. To integrate you know.
This discipline this academic discipline into a different. And to different fields.
You know not only in archaeology in a political context
but also in the maybe in the faculty in the department of our it because that is you know there's the other fix that is
the part about of the studies
and departments of Arabic stars in the Arab world we are in fact not you know totally concerned with the.
With the ancient sources that we encounter and E.B.M. Before Islam.
What is the essence of what they are finding what you're finding Yes In fact it's very essential to understand you know
cultural historical aspects on the basis of inscriptions For example we know that Arabia has had always a constant
contact with the with the surrounding I mean.
That we discovered through the inscriptions through the texts
and we know that for example that Arabia had contacts with Egypt with the with the greenies with the.
With the other with modern Turkey and minor and also with other remote areas for example.
Scimitar Semites there they reached you know Morrocco and Tunisia and Morocco and through the NS corruptions we can.
Find out how those people have this image that people in this area we're in a strong
and constant contact with other people in the world but why is it.
You work you work you find all these findings
and it's very important from a should we can we look around in a part of the world where all kind of conflicts emerge
now round Jordan. Which is all about historical.
Well Mr conceptions also I mean you have all kind of you have you have countries that say you have to believe this
and if you do it like that you have groups that say it's like this you should do to our steps can imagine that that is
a lovely feeling when you are in this in this. Part of the world where they treat history.
Yes In fact that's why it we have to understand history and the proper way. I mean we don't have to history.
You know this is this is the most dangerous think and you know every group.
You know tries to say that I am I'm the one who follows that I know that I through a you know
but this is this is not true. I mean we have.
Basic ground basic ground which we have to understand to understand it as it is you know we don't have to reflect our
political you know political backgrounds or. The culture of political ties.
I don't know whether I'm using the right word. If we understand culture and religion as well in the. Political context.
Definitely the reason there is a lot will be will be dangerous. You see that.
Yes In fact that's what what's happening now in fact in the surrounding the surrounding region. It's difficult.
Every every group has its own understanding and. They defend that in different ways.
Because the of the lack of cultural The I look you know and I'm dreaming of.
Could you explain to me what it means what you are doing and what people you work for tutoring for the and handsome
and of identity. Richmond's of the identity.
Yes In fact maybe as you have seen that I'm working in different fields but out of there are interrelated.
I'm using the information contained in the inscriptions. To. In order to reach a certain result. You know.
And I'm using also information gained from cultural heritage in general especially the intangible cultural heritage to
put search results together to show how cultural heritage and general. Is important for identity.
In fact identity is not contained only inscriptions but also in other sources I mean for example the A.B.N.
Poetry is part of our history as part of our identity on the Arabic poetry
and also the holy book is also part of our identity because it's written in Arabic and I think it's very crucial
and important. To understand what the.
Others wrote about the Koran and there are several institutions in there in Europe
and in the United States who take care.
I mean that study in a different from a different perspective and a different methodology.
A lot of studies appeared in the last twenty years about from Germany France and other.
And other countries in the world but I have the problem.
I think I would so just be going to make institutions in the Arab world. To start.
Understanding what the Europeans wrote about this about this book about this holy book in fact.
And so that we can understand from the methodology to live in how the European scholars study.
Because studying the traditionally would traditionally without taking into consideration the new publications written
in different languages. For example in German French or Russian No I think it would lead to kind of.
I don't know could lead to a kind of mis understanding of the others and there were concerns on
and because I mean it's for me important to show how how Europeans dealt with the core
and generally especially in the last twenty thirty years ago. All the literature about.
Mostly translated into Arabic and we knew what the contents of it but in the last twenty thirty years we have.
I mean Arab scholars who has no access to funnel languages.
This will remain for them close to me in the literature
and written in other languages other languages remains for them closed you know there are a lot about it.
That's why I said just that we. We are translating this into a brick. That's the core of who you are.
I mean language is the key. Yes are the key of cultures. And also to stand identity your own identity.
Yes of course I mean studying.
Well studying ancient written sources that are written in Arabian languages and studying also cultural connotations.
Their cultural backgrounds and this would should the light on the people who who wrote the mistakes
and also make them feel proud about our identity and understanding
and to understand that in a proper way to share for that reason the language the language is a language is form the
basis for years of course I mean I mean I mean the languages are out of the keys out of the keys to two cultures
and culture of cultural value values are contained in cultures
and studying the languages is of course the key to understand the cultural backgrounds.
I mean especially in regarding civilisations because they are you know they don't exist anymore
but we have their takes that that have been lifted. By those who composed composed them. We can get.
Get some glimpses about the cultural background from from the sticks and they would help us and Hansing the identity.
That's why your put work is so important. Thank you so much. Don't you think yourself.
You know of course I mean I think it's an important discipline which should be. I mean which should be supported.
I mean every Jordanian institution. Going to make institution and draining.
Yes of course I mean first of all we have to start in the academic institutions.
And then we should think in a further step how to disseminate this knowledge among.
The local communities so that also people that visit. Petra for example.
Understand what that really is and that's just like us because now it's sometimes used as a kind of.
Not only you know this is the difficult story to tell because a now.
Is being consumed if we remain investing it in this way I feel that is part of our identity here in Jordan
and we have to preserve it and save guard as a culture of space. You know for the future generations because it is.
I mean a site like but that is.
Is a place which is unparalleled I mean in the world and we are very proud to have it
but we have in the same time to do our best to safeguard it and also to present it in a proper way. And.
In addition to this into. Its being as part of our identity in Jordan.
I think it's also a source for income generation for for the national income. And I mean we can do. I mean.
We have the ability year in Jordan to.
To start working on the site in a proper way to conserve it and to safeguard it for future generations.
Yeah I mean this this this is also can be applied to other sites in Jordan as you mentioned before Jordan is a museum.
You know it's an open museum. I mean if you travel from the north to the south.
You always encounter cultural had a cultural heritage sites or nature inside.
And they constitute of course are part of our local identity but they only have to see it.
Yes I mean this is an important thing as well we have to make the people were aware of importance of such
archaeological science or heritage science in general and. You know it was my understanding it.
Stand their own identity. You know definitely and that was there and stand there more than just an Islamic.
Or just more than history in fact I feel that this part of this is not. I mean.
OK I mean I mean Islam is also as part of our history part of our identity
and I mean if you want to I don't know if you want to you want me to say it again where you can say it's.
You can say it again or you like. Yes In fact it's not only. The cultural heritage is part of our identity and.
The identity the religious identity of the people who are living in Jordan.
Is part of the entire identity of the Jordanian community.
I mean we have Muslims we have Christians here in Jordan but they constitute them.
Both religions here in Jordan are part of our identity as Jordanians in the whole Arab whole game as are ups of course.
So a lot of work to do for you. Yes In fact I am an individual but I'm trying my best and.
As I mentioned I hope that we can. Cooperate. I mean cooperate with the young generation to then to have.
You know a group of researchers ago a group of a group of interested people not only from the economic institutions
but also from the.
From the local communities to work together and to cooperate so that we can enhance our identity
and as Jordanians as Muslims Christians and as Arabs.